it's all right uh welcome back to the
workshop
um today's uh is the
transition day from quantum
to crypto or lattices uh as it may be uh
and today's uh uh topic is post quantum
cryptography um
which is this uh immense task of
redesigning the entire
cryptography field of cryptography to be
secure against quantum adversaries and
for a while we've known that this is
much more
about much more than
just replacing
factoring uh by lwe or hash functions or
whatever
uh really you have to you have to think
about proofs and reductions which are
of bread and butter and cryptography and
you have to these things break
spectacularly sometimes this spectacular
break can actually be translated into
good things and quantum but what alex is
going to talk about is something
different which is how to fix
systematically fix uh sort of proofs in
photography
starting with protocols
and this involves very interesting uh
very cool new techniques that combine
sort of what we know in cryptography and
recent techniques in uh uh from the
quantum world so uh so this is going to
be a three-part stock uh a real marathon
uh sort of a three-course uh
uh you know
uh three-course meal if you'd like
um and alex and for me will jointly give
the first off and then they will they
will they will switch right so uh and uh
you know any if anyone wants to sort of
ask a question uh you know i'll give you
the mic so so it's you know everybody in
the virtual world can hear you yeah
is the mic working
like working
okay sounds good hey everyone i'm alex
hi i'm fermi i'm a postdoc here at
simonson berkeley and so today we'll be
trying to distill as much as we can in
three hours about quantum rewinding
uh and so
i
have not actually given such a like
systematic overview of a field to such a
cool audience before but uh we're really
trying to optimize for your
understanding like really as much as
possible so although we have slides set
out to talk about stuff i would be just
as happy if you just interrupted with
questions we can go on the whiteboard
and talk about whatever you want
uh and hopefully we'll learn something
cool by the end of the day
so
uh and i've listed the like main works
that we're talking about in the first
hour so the first hour is an overview of
uh
as like basically all that we knew about
quantum rewinding like circa 2016 and
then there's been some cool work in the
last five years uh some of which we'll
get to in the second two laps
okay
so uh so vinod sort of stole the first
five minutes of this talk but that's
okay
uh so our goal for today is to get
host quantum cryptography which means
getting clat like having classical
cryptography that you know we can run
hopefully right now uh that is secure
against not just attacks that we can run
today but attacks by quantum computers
that might be built in 50 or 100 years
so that's the goal
uh and
like so what does that actually entail
how do you achieve that uh so in
theoretical cryptography what we do is
we take some computational problem that
seems intractable like a one-way
function or the hardness of factoring or
discrete logarithm or something like
that
uh we take this hard problem we use it
to build some cryptosystem and then we
prove
that if the cryptosystem is broken by an
efficient attack then we get an
efficient breaker of the assumed hard
problem and that's how
we do everything basically
uh so of course if we want post-quantum
cryptography we can't use quantum broken
assumptions uh that seems bad uh
but and uh and this issue has received
attention for it for probably almost 30
years by now
uh and you know in those 30 years we
have found some you know problems that
seem
at least as far as we can tell today
they seem hard to break even with an
efficient quantum attack and so that
gives us hope of having post-quantum
cryptography
uh and
at this point
we you might think that we can actually
just go home and not have the tutorial
because uh this seems pretty good
uh so so what is the problem uh so
so you might conjecture that as long as
nothing like really terrible is going on
uh if you plug a quantum hard problem
into this framework which has a
classical security proof that you should
get a post-quantum secure cryptosystem
and uh
and a lot of the time people actually
mistakenly like reason in this fashion
uh but this is actually like horribly
false
uh
and so here's one particularly cool
example demonstrating why
uh so there's this uh interactive proof
of quantumness due to prokaryotiana
mahada
vidiq and zazirani
and so what is this it's an interactive
protocol between approver and a verifier
such that
uh
no classical prover can make the
verifier accept with with like even
small probability assuming that learning
with theirs is hard
uh but such that there is even
prescribed efficient quantum proverb
that can make the verifier accept
so this is billed as a proof of
quantities a way to prove that you do
quantum computation
uh and and and this work and these
techniques actually let you build much
stronger proof systems than this effect
uh but we can also just view this as a
very very explicit counter example of
this conjecture
this that the soundness of this proof
system
is is classically true and we have a
proof of this
and yet the post-quantum soundness is it
is not postponed
alexa you probably address it but what
about natural
natural classical protocols that are
based on acoustic
sure so i mean that's what most of today
will be about
yeah but i'm gonna say i mean you know
there's a large number of reductions
where i think you know this kind of
argument does work right where you know
you know as long as the like in some
sense as long as the the the original
problem is only being queried you know
like a classical
yes if you have a if you have a if you
have a one call straight line reduction
then uh then
then then you're then you're fine right
we're just a small number of calls
uh
even
no even even more than if you do more
than one i i don't know of a general fan
okay yeah
understand the importance of reductions
but in terms of actual quantum attacks
against natural classical protocols
which are based on post-quantitative
consumption but yeah
well okay but it's but it's not a
protocol that was written down for like
like somebody somebody who wanted to
build a like classical cryptography
didn't write down this protocol though
right uh so well
we'll keep talking about it uh
so for example one thing you can ask is
take like a basic sigma protocol and be
like
if we plug in post quantum stuff is this
going to be post quantum secure uh and
the answer is still actually going to be
no uh but
but morally like morally we believe the
answer is that like
if you if you plug in things like
appropriately and you you know what to
do then things like should look secure
but
uh
but it's very hard to actually like
prove that this is the case
so like an example we thought about a
decade ago like you know the
construction of uh pseudorandom
generators from one-way functions that's
actually okay against quantum
adversaries right but then the
construction of pseudorandom functions
from pseudorandom generators you know
the ggm that breaks right because you
have these exponentially many queries
yes so yeah i think what i'm about to
say is pretty relevant to this
discussion
that's actually true
uh there's a recent work of zwika
and this is this is only
this
is you want to it's not clear that uh
it's not clear that it actually goes
through all the time uh
all right all right yeah yeah but it's
talking about when you want not like
security again with an
attacker with an auxiliary quantum state
and you don't want to start with
multiple copies of the state in the
reduction
uh anyway uh so
like let's let's at least understand why
the conjecture is false for this for
this example protocol
so so so what's going on uh
so
the
like
there is a classical proof of security
for this protocol and you would naively
expect that you should be able to plug
in like your quantum assumption or
your quantum attacker into this
reduction and get an attack on lwe but
that doesn't happen uh somehow the the
honest quantum prover is convincing the
verifier without breaking the assumption
and the reason is that the
way you prove classical security this
protocol involves rewinding the
adversary that is so so what happens
like inside inside this inside the
security proof you you take some prover
which is allegedly convincing the
verifier and you first of all like run
the prover once you see like what
happens in one execution of the protocol
so say it sends a message you send it a
challenge it sends you some response and
you say like record this information
uh and then what the reduction does it
says okay now we're going to actually
rewind the state of the of the attacker
to this earlier execution point after
just sent the first message
and then we're going to run it on the
difference like execution branch of the
protocol we're going to send it a
different question it's going to give us
a different answer we're also going to
learn so we're going to in particular
learn two
accepting transcripts in this protocol
uh and lwe is broken once you
find two
these these two accepting transcripts so
basically if you can break the protocol
twice then the computational assumption
is violated and classically if you can
break a protocol once you can also break
it twice
uh so this doesn't work in the quantum
setting because
at this you know execution point after
sending the first message the approver
may have so the adversary may have some
residual like quantum states
to obtain a response you have to measure
the states
uh this measure may be destructive and
afterwards you may not be able to use
the prover in a reasonable way this you
may not actually get a second accepting
transcript
we and we don't break the assumption and
this is not some like theoretical issue
this must actually be what is happening
for this protocol because there is a
there is a quantum classical separation
i mean you said break it twice
so i i i the the approver convinces the
verifier twice in two different
execution branches i rewind at once to
do that
okay so
so rewinding
is uh is kind of scary in the quantum
setting basically and so of course we
know this protocol is quantum broken but
i but the
the bigger takeaway from this actually
is not that there exists a like cool
protocol where rewinding like fails in
the quantum setting or or that or where
no proof of security exists but actually
whenever you prove security of anything
if you use rewinding there is actually
no guarantee that your protocol is post
or that your your object is post quantum
and uh and this
and
we use rewinding actually all the time
certainly if you have an object that
involves interaction you were with like
95 probability using rewinding to argue
security
somehow magically in the real world you
could rewind you could break it yes here
here you're talking about the adversary
being able to rewind you the honest
party so i'm curious whether this meets
in some
screen of an idea here that in
when you actually leave the protocol
attached and not do what you want to do
that makes it worse
could you make it secure
concurrently secure
yourself
yes you know that anyway they can't
reset in the real world somehow the
grain of that idea here and you're
you're trying to do one thing i'm saying
now yeah it sounds like what you're
saying is that maybe if you if the
honest parties are allowed to run uh
quantum computation which isn't
inherently non-rewindable this might be
a tool for you to get stronger security
properties and protocols that sounds
like resetting or
concurrency yes that's that sounds very
likely
so i think the statement i was thinking
of is like if you've got a small number
of queries in your reduction and there's
no rewind
there could be an attack like for
example as with ggf where where uh
there's a you know the quantum computer
could fire everything in superposition
right and attack against the proof
that's right that's right there are
there are quantumly secure
yes this ggm discussion like changes the
security definition of the prs so yeah
yeah so yeah
yeah and yeah then the bottom party
complexity becomes relevant
like if
function for example then you know
schwarz algorithm could find this period
yes
uh
okay so where we are right now is that
hopefully i've convinced you that we at
least need to oh sorry yes it's probably
a very dumb question what do you mean
like quantum broken
it's it's not broken by a quantum
adversary the soundness of the the
soundness of the the protocol is not
sound against quantum provers that is
what i mean that is what i said of
course that's not i am like you know uh
like giving a very different spin than
uh
than what they were saying but i this is
view this is in viewing it as a as a
like counter example to this like
security should be preserved conjecture
okay so
if you do rewinding it is not clear
whether your opposed quantum secure but
also
anything in cryptography that uses
interaction like most likely this is not
always true but it most likely uses
rewinding when analyzing security and so
at this point it is not clear whether
anything is secure and uh and
like scenes for me it's about things
assuming set up assumptions like crs or
correlated problems
what about them
sorry again we use set of assumptions
like a common reference string or
correlated randomness
right so that's a way of this is a way
of possibly enabling like a a straight
line reduction right yeah so so yeah if
you like build a the music that we know
from lw we are post quantum secure
immediately okay that's true okay
yes there's no rewind
and same
how about say you see secure protocols
in the crs model are they also quantum
secure so yeah you see security is uh
like is explicitly not allowing
rewinding right i need to i now need to
think i'm i'm not sure whether
how like how difficult uc security is in
the quantum
here you see settings this allows you
winding for the simulator that can still
have a reduction
yes exactly yeah i'm not actually sure
what happens question is about neutral
well for the rest of today we're only
going to be talking about natural
protocol so hopefully this like uh
satisfies the concerns
although i would call this proof of
quantum as a very natural protocol
that's not in the like in a in a
different context
okay so
for the rest of today we want to know
when
when you can do rewinding in the quantum
setting i just said in general you can't
but it doesn't mean that you can never
do it
uh and also we are free to change like
our definition of quantum rewinding we
do not have to do exactly what the
classical security proofs did uh we can
also use like quantum information
quantum algorithms to help us do
rewinding and we're going to be doing
that
all of today
uh if you have it turns out if you have
quantum adversaries using like uh
quantum algorithms in your reduction is
uh is helpful
uh
so
uh so for today we're focused on
interactive protocols for the rest of
today approver is trying to convince
some
verifier some claim perhaps represented
by a three-sets like uh problem but like
honestly whatever you want
uh i'll usually be thinking about an np
problem
um
and uh and the two properties we'll be
concerned about like analyzing today are
that's the two most basic properties
about a protocol we want it to be sound
meaning that a malicious prover can't
strip the verifier into putting
something false
and
uh we want to be zero knowledge uh which
uh says that's the verifier doesn't
learn anything from the interaction
besides the truth of the claim which you
formalize by saying that the view of the
verifier everything that it sees in the
interaction can be efficiently simulated
uh without the proof
uh so
these are the properties we're
interested in showing
um and so to be very explicit like we
said we were talking about post quantum
security so let's just specify like what
an attack is what what what a quantum
attack is
uh a quantum adversary is going to be
efficient so it's a polynomial time uh
it's going to we're going to represent
its computation by running a polynomial
size unitary and then measuring its
output register on the standard basis
and uh so you can of course have some
like classical input classical input
will will be put onto some some input
register adversary may also have some
auxiliary state psi
uh
all of this uh oh and uh and just also
just note like u is always going to be
efficiently invertible uh
this is true if you just think about
like what an efficient quantum circuit
is you can always delay measurements to
the end and you can always invert the
unitary gate by gate
and the last thing to mention is that
we're in the interactive setting so the
attack is actually going to be an
interactive algorithm which means that
it will
start possibly with some state and it
will be able to like maintain slash
updated states throughout the
computation every time that you query it
it can it can update its state and keep
it
okay so this is the model
and uh so for the rest of the talk
i'm going to just show you a single
interactive protocol and we're going to
be able to prove that the single
interactive protocol is both post
quantum sound and post quantum zero
knowledge and these are using the
pre-2016 like techniques
so this is uh this is what we're going
to do
you know that you can't necessarily
relate the measurements to the end if
you for example are running the protocol
and you uh
yeah only only for the next message i'm
going i'm just going to delay the
measurements in the next message
function until the end of that step i'm
not going to delay it until later in the
protocol
one measurement
yes
okay so
okay intro crypto recap uh
but we're going to consider this one
protocol due to bloom for proving a
graph has an n cycle where n is the
number of vertices
uh we want it to be zero knowledge so
you can't just send the end cycle uh so
what we're going to do is effectively
like convey a random end cycle to the
verifier in a way that you could you
could in principle link it to the graph
that you started with
so
that is what you do is you commit to
just say the adjacency matrix of a
random permutation of your graph
a commitment is just a cryptographic
implementation of this locked box so
after sending this message i'm stuck
with a particular adjacency matrix but
the verifier doesn't know what it is and
i can choose to show to reveal to the
verifier what the an individual entry is
later
uh then the verifier is going to send a
random bit to me and depending on and uh
and the bit is conveying basically one
of two questions either show me you
committed to an isomorphic copy of the
original graph or show me that you
committed to a graph that contains an n
cycle
so
either you just reveal
the entire adjacency matrix and the
permutation mapping the graph to this uh
to this graph
or you just reveal the edges uh in an
end cycle the verifier can check either
of those things
uh and accepts if the if the proof
you know
answered its one question reasonably
uh so this is the protocol
uh hopefully most of you have seen it
before
um but just to quickly convey like why
this should be secure so the the point
is that so this is going to be sound
because after sending this committed
graph you're you're stuck with a
particular adjacency matrix and if the
if the original graph does not have an n
cycle then you'll only be able to answer
one of the two one of the two questions
alternatively if you can answer both
questions then you know this particular
graph is both isomorphic the gn contains
an n cycle
uh
then so then why is it zero knowledge
well at like at a at a high level like
what at least you can see is that for a
fixed like question zero or one like
what the verifier sees doesn't seem to
reveal any information you either just
see a random isomorphic copy of g and
like randomness that you use to commit
to it
or you see a random cycle
along with a bunch of committed
adjacency matrix entity entries that you
can't actually see inside
so that's why this is this looks to zero
knowledge anyway
um so now uh let me tell you about how
to show that this is sound
against quantum attacks then firmly
we'll talk about why it's zero knowledge
against quantum attempts
uh
and uh okay so and uh and what's
actually going to happen here is we're
going to see like a more formal
classical proof of soundness then we're
going to introduce a new cryptographic
security definition that is actually
needed
to argue the post-quantum sound and so
like morally if you don't satisfy this
definition the protocol probably won't
be post quantum sound that's the intuit
it's not it's not formal but the we'll
we'll see we'll see
um
and uh and then we'll see like the uh
like a technical proof of soundness that
you can almost think of as like an
application of the gentle measurement
level actually
okay
so uh classical soundness so the
protocol has soundness error one half
meaning that if the prover can convince
the verifier more than half of the time
then the claim must be true
uh
so and and so the way that you show this
is by using what's called the two
special soundness of this protocol which
is a fancy way of saying that if you can
answer both questions then there is a
hamiltonian cycle which we have already
talked about if you've got an
isomorphism to g
like an opening and a nice work from the
g and an opening to a cycle you get a
psychology
are you assuming perfect binding
i
i do not need to assume perfect binding
for this
if you if you send me the openings
to this and openings to this
okay then by computational binding the
openings are consistent we're going to
talk about this
more later so don't worry if i'm going
too fast but yeah the openings will have
to be consistent and
you still get the cycle
you're saying that the two special
soundness is necessary like if you take
this recoloring basically
the proof technique i'm going to show
you does not apply to the three coloring
protocol which is uh
ridiculous but uh but we actually didn't
have a way to analyze the three coloring
protocol until last year
and that is why i i i picked we picked
this one protocol very carefully
but just for proof of knowledge right
for for normal assignments and you
wouldn't know how to do it before uh not
if the commitment is only
computationally fine
so with this list recovery called base
construction you can take any zero
knowledge pcp and make it satisfy this
property
sorry make it satisfy what property
the two special summons can you compile
any zika dcp
this work that you had with the
we don't convert it into something
that's too special sound
yeah we can we convert it into into into
a protocol where the number of choices
of bad randomness is a polynomial
so it's still open to get general
compiler i think that's right
sorry for this digression we're going to
go through this right now uh
okay but at least here yeah if you're
gonna if you get if you obtain accepting
transcripts on both challenges crucially
for the same
commitment the same first message
then you can you can find the
hamiltonian cycle in the breath
and so now the way you prove security is
by rewinding if you have approver which
is convincing what you'll do is you'll
call it once on the zero challenge and
once on the one challenge
and if the prover is more than half
convincing then there is a decent
or non-negligible probability
that the approver will answer both of
your questions correctly at which point
you have you've shown the graph is
hamiltonian
so this is a really formal classical
proof of sentence
so so what about the post quantum
setting uh sort of as we were just
discussing if the commitment is
perfectly binding
uh if if really after sending the commit
the commitment string the graph is
information theoretically determined
then there is nothing to say like you
like the protocol is actually
information theoretically sound so it is
also sound against quantum attacks
uh
so another another like
another way to interpret what i just
said is that you can apply this what you
can do is you could take a quantum
adversary replace it by an inefficient
classical simulation and then apply this
rewinding argument to the inefficient
classical simulation
is it by the way true that the
information classical security always
implies security against quantity it
does not if it's a proof of knowledge
it's just not
uh so yeah if you think about yeah you
want this to be a proof of knowledge
what i just said doesn't make any sense
like you i'd be trying to apply proof
knowledge extractor to an inefficient uh
simulation and it doesn't give you what
you want
i just wanted to simplify things and
only talk about soundness mostly
uh so yeah so the interesting case here
is what happens if the commitments are
only computationally binding
uh
but to like understand what that means
we also have to understand what
computational binding
actually means in the quantum setting
uh so yeah so what it what what is
computational binding for a commitment
so here's the here's the classical
definition
so in a commitment
you commit to some to some string m
using some randomness d
to open for today to open the
commitments you'll just send m and d
and the and whoever you committed to the
receiver will check that
that your opening is valid that they'll
recompute the commitment say
uh and uh and the scheme is binding if
after sending a commitment an adversary
can't come up with openings to two
different messages can't both show that
they committed to like the zero string
into the one string whatever
uh
and so
uh so naively you would just say well
let's just take this definition and say
that it's that assume that it holds
against quantum attacks
uh and you'd like to then plug this into
the protocol and say that you get
something sound that's i think what you
would
maybe what you would even expect but if
you're if you were like uh processing
what's been going on then maybe you can
like sense that there is an issue here
because the security definition is
talking about simultaneously having two
openings
and intuitively this is not like a
physical
there's not a physical statement because
the way you obtain two openings is by
rewinding
like you know if you're using the
commitment somewhere the way you would
have two different openings just by
running somebody into like twice
and so
that is sort of hinting that this is not
actually the right security definition
in the quantum setting because you may
only have somebody that's that that like
behaves correctly once
uh so and in fact this can be like
formalized into a counter example saying
that this security definition is
insufficient
for soundness
so in particular yeah so here's the just
the so what's the confidence
yeah it's right here
so
yes this is just the naive definition
again like maybe we should just assume
the quantum attacker can't open to two
different strings
uh and so the issue do the aru
is that you can actually write down a
commitment scheme which first of all
satisfies this definition it will be
hard to do this even for quantum
algorithms
however
you can construct such a scheme with the
following property with the following
attack that you can run
you can send some commitment string
and then later
take any message that you like
and then create an opening
for that message so you have some
auxiliary state and some particular
measurements of your state will produce
an opening of the commitments to like an
arbitrary string m of you're choosing
however
this security definition holds so that
so provably the attack can only do this
once
and so first of all hopefully like uh if
you think about it you should see that
like this means the scheme is super
broken you should not consider this a
good commitment scheme so is this
analogous to the burkarsky christianity
uh
well
i wouldn't say it's like uh
super analogous but it is true that you
can answer a question like an arbitrary
question once and you can't answer it
twice
because it disturbs the state yes i mean
basically every yeah every example like
because the question is rewinding yeah
so why didn't give this a proof of
quantumness because then when we're
built
oh yeah so yeah so this is uh yeah this
is this is relative to an oracle
and uh
and it's it's it's like still uh yeah
interesting question like when you can
actually do this
just question why isn't there be
progressive
uh
it is a morally similar kind of thing
but
oh no it's just it's just that this is a
this is like not the strongest possible
counter example like the fact that it's
relative to an oracle just sort of says
that like you can't sh given a
commitment scheme you can't you probably
can't show or it'll be hard to show that
this attack doesn't exist
like that that's the that's the
downstream implication the average rate
of use of the oracles
yes so okay but but another answer okay
no the you know scale will not actually
give you this will not give you a
counter example because such a counter
example basically implies quantum money
it turns out
uh but i don't really want to get into
it
yeah but you can yeah like this uh this
kind of uh commitment scheme turns out
to be a way to instantiate quantum money
a lot of money already have another
definition uh yeah to fix this yes
alex
i yeah so don't don't quote me on it
gets complicated but uh
uh
do you have to remember i'm not sure
yeah i'm not sure either
i think i think you get something
interesting
okay so
so what definition are we actually going
to use like this says that that this
definition is not the right definition
to be considering uh so we're going to
write down a definition that avoids this
attack at least
happens right the moment you do a test
you know the object is destroyed right
that's what gives you the counter
example
so it seems the opposite of
what you want no no but you have some no
but i think you have some kind of
unclone ability you can get one opening
to your commitment and you can't get
multiple openings to your commitments
don't mean that there's quantum money
like it's true like you have to choose
how to measure so for example like with
my impulse scheme you could get a a
an element of the subspace or you could
get an element of the dual subspace and
you can't get better
i'm not sure if that's connected to this
right
you know it would probably probably the
thing
it's an opening to a random message is
some sort of like uh
unclonable signature type object let's
see itself here is sort of like the
quantum money like if you could double
this thing
okay so let's actually see how like how
we're going to deal with this so we're
going to write down a stronger security
definition that turns out to actually
correspond to like protocol security
when you plug it in
uh and so what we're going to do is
we're going to write down a statistical
property of a commitment scheme which is
statistically binding and then assume
that a computational variance of this
holds that's how we're going to get the
definition and the the property is going
to be like a more quantum property that
will like therefore correspond to like
breaking the commitments in the quantum
settings better
so so
so basically take a commitment scheme
consider the following experiment
suppose that some adversary produces for
you a commitment string and some state
consisting of super like a super
position over openings to your stream
uh
and uh so we're really interested in the
setting where the openings are valid so
just basically imagine that like uh that
somebody has like measured whether or
not the opening is correct and like
thrown away like the part of the state
where this is not true so morally just
assume the adversary always sends you
like valid openings you can check
anywhere
then the statistical property which
holds in when your scheme is perfectly
binding
is that you can measure the message
register m
and not change the states only up to
like very small trace distance
the reason is that if the commitment is
fixed and you have a valid opening you
know the method is uniquely determined
and so measuring it doesn't do anything
so so this this is true for a
statistically binding scheme and the
the
binding definition the computational
binding definition and the quantum
setting is simply going to be that this
holds
computationally so if the adversary can
produce a commitment and valid openings
then measuring the message is a
computational the undetectable operation
so
this is what we're going to like use it
might be sort of unclear why this is the
right property but at least hopefully
uh
you can intuit that this is at least
stronger than the previous definition
it's actually not like
super immediate but it's not too hard to
see that if you could open if you could
produce two different classical openings
then this definition doesn't really have
a chance of being true because basically
that like an adversary could detect
whether a superposition between two
known valid classical openings is broken
or not by this measurements
so you're saying
yes
and uh
so basically the issue is that a quantum
adversary can have a state yeah
where you know that the state contains a
valid opening
to the commitments but the message is
not like is is not determined there is
still like the you still have a
superposition so the word adversary
cannot tell whether or not m is measured
or whether that commitment contained it
no so the adversary actually produced
this state the adversary produced the
commitment and the superposition over
openings
and so the point is that you want to
argue that there's only like one
accessible message like
like although there is a supervision
over openings there's really only one
message that is accessible to the
verifier
the definition is given
no no mnd are the are the are the
registers for this state
the explicit experiment is the adversary
sends you a state you perform a
measurement or you don't and then you
send the state back to the adversary and
the adversary and then runs a
distinguisher
okay so
still it's like probably not clear why
you want to use this definition
uh
what was d again
d is the open like the think of like the
randomness used to generate the
commitments or something like that
okay so at the very least this this
definition does rule out the kind of
attack that we just talked about
uh
because
the like an attack that like can open a
commitment to an arbitrary message
definitely like doesn't like you have
access to many different messages in
that situation
uh
and uh it'll turn out to be compatible
with our rewinding arguments that that's
what we'll see and then like another
nice thing is that if you just like take
two of these commitments and then like
do a composition like commits to the
commitments that you had before like
some operation like this this property
will end up being preserved which is
good
uh and so also luckily we can construct
such commitments uh assuming learning
with errors you can also a random oracle
is collapse binding for example so like
you you can write down such commitments
and and for the rest of today we're just
going to be using commitments that
always satisfy this segment so this is a
very different kind of definition
rather than the usual definition of
binding to solving such problems right
uh it's great yes
is there a sense that this this
definition is necessary
uh well the aru the aru arguments is is
not
quite
this
but it is
it and it's oh and in fact the uh
if you have a commitment scheme which is
not collapse binding again weird things
are going on basically and and you can't
quite say that you can execute the aru
attack but like
it
it seems fairly close to a statement
that you can execute an aru style attack
and if you can decide later to
equivocate your commitment to any
message at all then it's not very secure
this definition is like very quantum is
there kind and i would have no idea how
to prove it like is there is there some
somewhere
yes
slightly to say that no computationally
bounded adversary
can give a state of opening and
determinant
such that that state has a unique amp
like if i measure it the m register and
then literally to statistically close
after measuring uh you're asking so
you're at so you're saying
your
strength in the security or sorry one
second yeah yeah you're saying to
strengthen the security definition you
just want that if the initial adversary
was was bounded right that the
measurement is is statistical is is
statistically undetectable
much more intuitive definition
but i don't know what is it is it
becoming hard to construct or it's not
satisfying yeah i think it's or rather
if you're if you i think it's only
satisfiable if your scheme is
statistically binding basically
if you're if your question
possible
you just commit to the superposition of
everything and then measure the
commitment string and
your your m register will have stuff in
it
that's only for compressing or
if this counter example is for
compressions
you know the
trick to this definition is gives you
statistically uh somewhere statistically
mining right now
you want even if you are you're
compressing you could be binding in one
location and then that's sort of uh
okay uh
we're running rather late so i'm gonna
try to go a little faster and firming
hasn't even started yet
uh so so what does what does collapse
binding actually buy you how do we
actually use it so there's actually a
very clean answer to this question
the answer is that we're going to change
how you run an attack
because like whenever you run an attack
you're not actually going to run the
attack because running an attack
disturbs the adversary state too much so
we're just going to generically come up
with a way to run that run an attack
while disturbing the state less and
that's going to help
so normally
in a protocol when you run an attack say
you feed it a string r it had some state
psi
and you like run some computation and
measure output register to get a string
z and send it back that's what running
the attack normally would
and this could disturb this the state a
lot in particular is if z is a long
string and there's a lot of statistical
disturbance to the states
however
when like whenever you're using an
attacker
it is not usually important that you
have the string z
if it's not actually an accepting strike
if it doesn't make the verifier accept
like a string z which is invalid is not
generally that useful
and uh and so actually we're going to
just change the way we run the attack so
that we only gets the string z
if it is a valid response
and this is going to actually save us a
lot of disturbance
uh so
like so what you can do is define
projective measurements which just
checks so it's a measurement say on the
adversary state
which
which just checks whether uh whether z
is valid so like run the computation
check whether z is valid undo the
computation one bit measurement
uh and so we're going to just always so
now from now on instead of running our
attacks we're going to run them in this
lazy way where lazy is with respect to
measurements just like measure less
where we first measure
whether pi r holds
and then we measure z
the answer only if the first measurement
outcome is one
so
and morally the collapsing property of
the commitment scheme
is going to say that this second
measurement is computationally
undetectable so you have to be a little
careful
to actually show this it depends on
what's on what this z actually is
but like if you are careful you can
usually show this
uh
so
uh
so now this means that we're actually
only disturbing the perverse states by
sort of like a one bit measurements it's
only the pi r i minus pi r measurements
that's actually disturbing the state at
least the second one is computationally
not
so uh so now we're only like you can
basically always pretend in your minds
at least when you're thinking about how
disturbed the prover state is that
you're only disturbing it by a one bit
measurement
uh and so now uh let's like so now let's
prove the soundness of one's protocol
finally yes
a single cubic measurement can still
disturb the state quite a lot it's just
it's more matter i assume you're very
close to accepting that single keep it
measurement and that's
that is exactly what's going to happen
yeah that's the situation where we're
going or well
you know it turns out somewhat strangely
that even if you only have like a
noticeable chance of of uh of the
measurement accepting you're going to
get a non-trivial statistical fact
uh so
so what so what this technique the lunar
technique can show is that the blunt
protocol has sinus error one over the
square root of two
which first of all like why
like what is this number uh it's it's
kind of out of nowhere but it but it's
it's essent it ends up just pointing to
the the like the limitations of the
security technique you expect the
soundness error to be one half but we
didn't have a proof of this until last
year
uh
so this technique will can show you that
the soundness error is one over square
root of two
uh
another caveat about like instantiating
the scheme correctly but let's forget it
today i'll just show you a weaker
statement which is just that you have
like a non-trivial soundness error
uh and the just because the proof is
easier but the like the style of proof
is morally similar
so so here's here's the proof suppose
you have a prover that's fairly
convincing uh like
with probability actually close to one
now think of delta is small
uh then
we're going to rewind we're going to do
a rewinding argument right so what we're
going to do is we're going to try to
obtain two transcripts by feeding in two
random challenges as as you would
basically expect but we're going to do
this lazy execution of the prover so we
don't disturb the proper state as much
and now the argument is simply that
uh you know because
of this of the collapsing property you
can basically think about just applying
these like these binary measurements of
checking whether the prover would answer
correctly
and then the claim
is simply that if you apply two of these
measurements in a row you still have a
high chance of both of them accepting
and the reason is is is a direct
application of the gentle measurement
limit the first one had a very high
probability of accepting you can show
that in this situation the prover state
barely changes and therefore the second
one will still accept with high
probability so this sort of attacks the
state disturbance problem very head-on
and just information that theoretically
bounds how much disturbance there is and
says that you can still run it twice
uh and this applies in the setting where
delt where the where you have a very
close to one probability of making the
verifier accept and so the full
soundness proof is invoking collapsing
to say that you can sort of reduce the
disturbance to applying binary
measurements this gentle measurement
arguments uh to to show that applying
two of these measurements in a row will
will like both produce valid answers uh
and then finally invoking special sound
is to say that we now have two accepting
transcripts and so we can reconstruct
the words so
this one over square root of two is
going to come from the square root in
the general measurement it is not this
measure this this lemma only implies
like uh like uh i don't know like some
some number around point nine instead of
one over square root of two
so the actual argument is is more subtle
than this it says
this is due to
and it says that if you were p
convincing
originally
then when you apply these two random
like when you try twice that you have a
p cubed probability
of uh producing two accepting
transcripts so classically the answer is
p squared and and um shows that in the
quantum setting you can show a bound of
t cubed and this p cubed turns out to
like translate to a one over square root
of two because of course it does
[Laughter]
uh so uh so yeah this is this is
basically like a you can think of it as
like a multiplicative error analog to
the kind of argument that we are making
like you don't want to think about
additive states but some kind of
multiplicative error in some sense
yeah just consider the first execution
as like as like as bad as possible on
your states just argue that you're still
like good enough later
okay and so
i still don't know of a simple proof
that this protocol has soundness error
one half even though it obviously should
uh but i don't know how to show it uh we
we have a proof a much more complicated
proof from last year
and uh so now fermi will talk about zero
knowledge in nine minutes
it may be a very quick question just the
exams
the more complicated arguments can argue
about the parallel repetition directly
yes this is implicitly showing that you
have a proof of knowledge because we are
the extractor actually outputs these two
transcripts and so you can extract the
witness
[Music]
so in these uh last few minutes we'll
cover the post quantum zero knowledge of
plum um so i'll do that by just
recalling how we formally prove zero
knowledge classical settings against
delicious classical verifiers and then
we'll see this really beautiful argument
due to
watrus although presented with a
different technique
also due to marion modric
um
great and the analysis is going to be
through something called jordan's llama
which is going to be a really important
technical tool for basically the rest of
today
okay so the key property that allows you
to prove zero knowledge in the classical
setting um is this observation that you
can simulate the view of any honest
verifier in this protocol so remember an
honest verifier is one who according to
the protocol will just sample a random
bit and that's its challenge
no matter what it receives it's going to
send a random bit
and the way that you sample uh
um the honest verifiers do is you sample
the challenge first right so you use
samples random r prime and then you
generate the transcript according to the
challenge so basically doing this out of
order is what's going to allow you to
sample something that looks like a valid
transcript right so when r prime is zero
the verifier is going to expect to see a
permutation of the graph so you're just
going to sample a random permutation of
the graph and commit to that
and that's c z is going to be the
opening and correspondingly when r prime
is one the verifier wants to see a
random cycle graph so you just sample a
random cycle graph commit to that
and by hiding these these transcripts
generated according to this procedure
look like the honest verifier view
because you can't tell that the
commitments in the first message are
dishonestly generated
right so that's honest verifier is your
knowledge but we want real zero
knowledge we want um security against
arbitrary malicious verifiers and what's
the thing malicious verifiers can do in
this protocol well they can pick the
challenge adaptively based on the first
message and so we need to show how to
simulate the view of a verifier that
does that
and the idea is actually pretty simple
um
the starting observation is that you can
simulate a malicious verifier with
probability one half and so with one
half probability you correctly simulate
the review and otherwise you just
totally fail and it's a simple guessing
simulator where you just sample a random
transcript random honest verifier view
you run the verifier on that first
message in the honest verifier view you
get some challenge r
and if r equals r prime then you're in
luck because that's exactly the
challenge that you know how to open to
right so then you're done that's when
the simulation succeeds and uh
but otherwise the simulation fails
and then you just need one more idea to
go from this to the full simulator which
is just that well if you fail you can
just try again
so that's the whole thing but because
this thing this this gassing simulator
succeeded probably one half and that's
due to the hiding property right this
verifier can't avoid this random r prime
that you're picking right because c is
hiding it so it's probably one half the
guessing simulator works and you just
try this a lot of times and you'll
succeed
okay so
unfortunately this simulator isn't going
to suffice for uh post-quantum zero
knowledge right the problem is that uh
when you have a malicious verifier who
has some initial quantum states then
running this guessing simulator might
disturb it so the issue is absolutely
important that's the yes yeah if there's
no auxiliary input you can actually do
it just this works
um but the soundness error is only one
half and so if you want a real protocol
you'll have to repeat its sequence and
then the second time you won't be able
to show
on this side
[Music]
so maybe in these last few minutes i'm
just going to speed through uh washer
says better
you can take the movement
10 10 again
okay great so watch this shows is that
if the equipment scheme is hiding
against quantum attacks then the blum
protocol is post quantum zero knowledge
um and luckily for us we don't have to
go and redefine hiding again for this
definition uh you can actually just take
the classical definition and replace tpt
with gpt and it works so
thankfully we can just go straight to
improving security
okay so
um
the starting observation for this
watcher simulator
is that this guessing idea like it still
works and that if you have the verifiers
uh like state psi like once um you can
run this guessing simulator once and
with one half probability you do succeed
and simulate this
malicious verifier's view the problem is
that if you don't succeed you're out of
luck because
how do you run it again you don't have
another copy of psi
okay so
as a first step we're just going to
write this process as a quantum circuit
so this here it i know it looks
complicated but this is really just a
single unitary u that's going to write
down like what this process above is
doing so this is like some process
that's happening on this quantum state
psi i'm going to write it as this as a
reversible quantum circuit
um so of course it's going to have
registers for basically every classical
value that appears in this in this
execution so r c z r prime and just to
make sure that they're quantum certainly
can generate the randomness that you
need in this guessing simulator so this
honest verifier simulator has to sample
random points we're going to give some
more h registers for for that
um
all right so what i've written down just
has the property that if you apply this
quantum circuit to psi and some ancilla
zeros and you check if r equals r prime
that's essentially the same thing as
running a discussing simulator the
probability that you measure r equaling
r prime is going to be one half
so all we've done so far is restate the
guessing simulator in more
quantum friendly language
and one last definition i'm going to
introduce this projector pi g and all
this is going to do is this is a
projective measurement or projection
corresponding to running the simulator
and conditioning on a successful result
so um that's what this measurement
corresponds to and what we want to do is
given psi or deterministically produce
this state this conditional state of
condition on the simulator accepting
and just for technical reasons like once
you have the state simulating the view
requires applying ug one more time and
then tracing some registers out but
really the goal is produce this
conditional state
with norm one
okay so
here's the very very rough intuition um
so
each of these if i apply this pi g
measurement on my states that
corresponds to one attempt of the
guessing simulator and classically what
we do is we just keep guessing over and
over again but this is a projective
measurement right so just naively
applying it again does nothing for me
it's just going to give the same outcome
um so instead of just doing the same
measurement twice in a row we're going
to write down some other measurement m0
that's going to happen in between any
applications of two pi g's
and intuitively m0 is going to serve to
like reset our attempt so that every
time we could basically try again
but formally what this means is uh
we're going to alternate these two
measurements back and forth so one is mg
which is the
projection protective measurement
corresponding to pi g and the other is m
zero which is the productive measurement
corresponding to pi zero where pi zero
is the projection onto
the ancillas being zero
okay these are the ancillas for running
this uh um this unitary discussing unit
and we just alternate these things back
and forth and we just keep going until
this mg measurement accepts
okay and we know that because of the
projective measurement once it accepts
the state is going to be in the image of
pi g
but
moreover it turns out the state is not
just in the image of pi g but it turns
out to be this particular state exactly
the one we wanted and that's going to be
the analysis we'll see why that actually
happens
um and finally once you have that it's
straightforward to generate the
verifiers view
okay so
here's the pretty important that the
probabilities of the two events are
roughly half and half like if
skewed yeah they'll be there you're at
this
this
was
the face
yes i know if if you want to just guess
if there were
if there were three challenges and you
guessed one of them
yeah sorry it's a
maybe i misinterpret your question but
if it's like any polynomial size
challenge space this idea works too
all right so why does this work uh
there's really two things to resolve one
we've already said uh the other is like
we actually want to know that this will
terminate right i was describing this
very informally is like do this thing
until x happens but why do we know x is
going to happen how long does it take
um and finally like once this happens
why is a state this particular simulated
state
yeah so m0 uh so you notice at the very
start you have psi tensor zero and you
have a state that's kind of if you
applied m0 to it would guarantee it
accept right m0 kind of corresponds like
where you're starting at the beginning
and mg corresponds to basically a target
it's like where you want to go you want
to be like in the like conditional space
corresponding to like a successful guess
and so we're going to alternate like
where you started with where you want to
go back and forth until you're where you
want to go and magically
it actually like not only takes you
there but takes you to the exact state
you wanted to get to
uh and it's a magic property of this
particular scheme that i'll say in a
second
okay so um let's just unpack this a
little bit like in general what is
happening when you alternate two binary
outcome projective measurements back and
forth
so getting intuition for this is going
to be pretty essential for
understanding both watchers and actually
the um the next two talks
so um
for me the easiest way to think about it
is to look at this 2d picture so just
think about two projectors that live in
two dimensions that's like clearly not
the situation we have here we're on more
than one cubit um
but just just suppose you live in two
dimensions and you have two projectors
that are both projecting onto a single
single vector so they're one-dimensional
projectors they have and they're uh like
orthogonal space is also one-dimensional
okay so then you have this picture here
where the key point is that pi a and pi
b like make this angle with each other
it's angle theta
right and you start in the image of pi a
and when we alternate the measurements
um back and forth what's going to happen
is you're going to sort of jump between
only four possible states
right so there's four states v w w perp
v perp and uh there's this value p that
basically corresponds to your jumping
probability like when i apply this
pi v measurement i have like a p chance
of going to the pi b outcome and a one
minus p chance of the other outcome
right and if you look at this picture
there's like the symmetry where that's
always going to be true right like you
can use this to compute basically where
you're going to go at every single step
with what probabilities
so you can just sort of watch this thing
evolve it'll jump around
um
and so the dynamics of this are really
easy to write down you can just follow
this diagram and using this it's a
fairly straightforward computation to
show that the time it takes for pi b to
accept just as a sum function of p
that it's an except in lambda over p
steps with overwhelming probability
so it really depends on how close you
were to p and this is like kind of like
matches up with your intuition right if
you were reasonably likely to get it in
one try then then it says that uh it
shouldn't take you too many tries to
actually make it happen
great so um claim two this one's uh
uh sort of immediate is that when this
thing accepts you actually do have the
right conditional state in that like you
get pi b times v
but only in this 2d case
so okay in 2ds in in two dimensions
the guarantees we get are
these these guarantees really correspond
to what we want to get from our
simulator but
our simulator does not work in two
dimensions so what's going on
um
so you can ask like do these claims
extend to higher dimensions
for general projectors actually they
don't
so we'll actually be exploring this in a
lot more detail in later talks um sort
of what actually happens for general
projectors but for our particular
projectors when we wrote down to the
simulator the answer is yes thankfully
um
and the useful tool we're
employ to think about this is called
jordan's llama
and this says that for any two
projectors in high dimensions you can
decompose the overall culvert space at
state space into a bunch of
two-dimensional slices you can actually
also be one-dimensional but those are
sort of uh
degenerate two-dimensional spaces so
there's a bunch of two-dimensional
slices sj
where in every single one of these
slices you basically recover the picture
we had on the previous
slide so in each one of these slices the
projectors act as rank one projectors
they're projecting onto a single state
and so you can so any state that you
have in general has potentially like
it's a superposition over these
different subspaces
and in each subspace it behaves as it
does like when you alternate these
measurements back and forth they will
behave as they do in the 2d case um but
in general it's harder to it gets more
tricky to understand what happens
because the subspaces have different
angles
okay so this is the general case um but
i claim that in our case that we can
actually get a pretty good handle on
what these angles look like and so
for that we need this key fact which is
that for any state phi the image of our
projector pi zero you have that
the norm squared of pi g applied to phi
is one half
so
why uh this is actually just kind of
immediate from the definitions we've
given um
and so what is phi if phi is in the
image of pi zero by definition of pi
zero it has to be of the form like psi
tends or zero
right so zero on the enceladus and that
means you can interpret this state that
you can interpret like applying pi g to
the state as running the guessing
simulator on a verifier and we know that
when you run a guessing simulator or a
verifier the
probability you guessed correctly is one
half
so this is true just for any phi image
of pi zero and
what this means when you look at this
jordan picture is that all the subspaces
have to have the same angle and in
particular that angle of course is 45
degrees it corresponds to
uh it's cosine squared has to be one
half
because if any subspace didn't look like
this you'd immediately get a state that
violates this fact
so
in this particular case when all these
angles look like this you can extend the
2d analysis to the simulator so i'm very
low on time so maybe i'll skip the
analysis that i planned and i'll just
i'll say the high level analysis which
is the reason why the 2d claims extend
to this is you could imagine like if all
the angles were exactly the same
not just almost one half but they were
exactly one half
then you can pick the jordan
decomposition
so that your initial state lies in a 2d
subspace
and because it starts in a 2d subspace
when you alternate these measurements
back and forth it stays there and these
particular properties that we proved in
the 2d case extend
so in the general case when it's just
very very close to one half
you have to make a much more careful
argument but it's still true
so i'm gonna skip all these
um
and uh
that's basically it though that explains
why our simulator satisfies this
efficiency property and why at the end
you get the right conditional state
you can um because all the angles are
the same you can sort of pretend that
your state
begins in a 2d subspace
so it's like you're not changing like
the
uh the amplitudes are referred to
different eigenvalues
yes that's the the more careful way to
argue it it's that um when you do these
alternating projections the the outcomes
are just giving you signal on the angle
uh or like basically the pj and the
difficulty with like proving that you
get the right simulated state is that
you don't you can't like destroy the
coherence across the different subspaces
and so when all the angles are the same
you
don't so the reason this happens
because of the true projectors
it's nothing to do with the adversary
right
g and pi zero and height of the
yeah but it says like for any
advertising unitary i can write down it
induces a pi g and that pi d must
satisfy this property or else finding or
else hiding it may be violated
search i'm trying to understand about
the key they have to make your life
difficult like if i recall the married
watchers there you typically take the
top eigenvector of your pound
and then you can show essentially using
your argument that you're stuck in a 2d
subspace and you can do the analysis
there basically
so yeah but in a mattress
so in area watchers uh are you talking
about like accepting that's right yeah
so if i give you a witness like i think
in their analysis actually they just
assume they give you one in a 2d sub
space you can it's just about the
existence
of this operator otherwise it doesn't
work the analysis right so yeah do you
think the top one because that's the
best example yeah exactly but here like
we don't get to pick where the verifier
starts the verifier can pick to sort of
try to make our simulator fail yes so we
might not be able to okay right exactly
yeah it's like on fires
okay so
let me just quickly recap what we saw
today so um we showed that blum's
protocol is zero knowledge and sound
against quantum attacks so for soundness
the two key ideas this notion of
collapse binding which allows you to run
a malicious quantum prover in this lazy
way and only only measure it when you
need to and we combine that with the
it's a gentle measurement rephrasing of
of unruslama um but more generally
unresolved lets you argue that if you
have a protocol where the responses are
collapsing meaning that you can measure
them undetectably um then any time you
have a successful adversary you can
extract two typing transcripts
for zero knowledge our key tool was to
kind of the key idea was to obtain a
quantum analog of this like repeated
classical guessing simulator and we
analyze these alternating projectors
using
st jordan's lemon
so why are there two more talks um on
part two
we're going to see you know can you do
better than under islam right unuru says
you can extract when you
need when you need two transcripts what
if you need more transcripts
um and part three
watch versus rewinding applies to a
really limited class of protocols where
the way that you simulate is by repeated
guessing but there's a lot of
interesting protocols where that is not
how simulation works and so how do you
prove zk if that's the
uh case a little bit late uh but uh
let's uh let's just 15 minutes break and
uh